welcome to the lighthouse thank you can
we take a little video hi Mr President
it is in honor of France rights of human
rights are we dropped us at the White
House
some of the bravest the most inspiring
people I've ever known
[Music]
thank you
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's June 13 2023 and I just want to say
if you're watching this program right
now you are the bravest and most
inspiring people I've ever known and I
mean that can I sniff your hair
what a weird world we live in is this
real life remember that original uh
YouTube video from way back when it's
like 15 out it could be 20 years old at
this point like one of the first ever
viral videos is this real life this kid
I think his name's David actually who
gets something done to his teeth and
he's sitting in the back you guys
remember that video that old viral video
we should have played that at the top of
the show and he's drugged because
they've just done something to his teeth
he's probably like six years old at his
dad's videotaping him and he's like is
this real life and that's basically how
we all wake up every morning every
morning you wake up and there's another
trans drag queen at the White House and
a man with dementia telling them that
they're brave for oh God
anyway uh we're very excited about the
program today we've all agreed it's a
rare moment of agreement that we all
said Today's show is going to be a 9-8
so the bar has been set high and of
course we have a post game show at
reubenreport.locals.com and uh Brock
tomorrow can we announce the special
giveaway for new annual subscribers
we'll give away some merch if they
subscribe annually can I commit to that
tomorrow
Thursday Thursday we will commit to that
on Thursday obviously things are
happening in the merchandise Department
which is a closet in a side bedroom over
here today's program is about the
machine people it is out of control it
is coming for you your family and your
children we've got characters in today's
play known as Gavin newsomeran DeSantis
Donald Trump Joe Biden Andrew Tate RFK
Jr and how all of these people actually
are parts of what's going on right now
some of them good some of them bad the
backdrop obviously today to Today's show
is that at three o'clock today Donald
Trump will be at this federal courthouse
in Miami to be clear this has nothing to
do with the state of Florida there are
federal courthouses in every single
state uh he happens to be being called
to one in Miami to deal with these
latest charges we'll get into that and a
bunch more in just a moment but before
we do let me talk to you about CB
Distillery uh you guys know that I tore
my left ACL and I tried every solution
there was out of all the remedies CBD
from CBD Distillery was incredibly
helpful given how much pain relief it
brought to my ACL and I'm playing ball
again CB Distillery is over 2 million
satisfied customers with 90 percent of
them reporting that they sleep better
with CBD 81 saying they have a reduction
in stress thanks to their CBD and eighty
percent of them saying their aches and
pains are relieved from their CBD after
physical activity so if you struggle
with sleep stress pain or if you're just
frustrated with the health concern
that's not getting better try CBD from
the source side trust
cbdistillery.com let me get you on the
right path with my 20 discount visit
cbdistillery.com and enter my name Dave
for your discount no prescription
required that's cbdistillery.com promo
code Dave for 20 off and now back to me
all right first off
warning people were about to show you an
evil lizard person from another planet a
man who is a lizard a cold-blooded
lizard who has taken the skin of a human
being put it on and become the governor
of California yes I am talking about
Gavin Newsom uh he went on Sean Hannity
last night now I will actually give him
a tiny bit of credit here he went on Fox
news on Sean Hannity that is not a
friendly he actually went on and did it
uh and uh well of course he exposed
himself to be the utter fraud and
really just terrible human being that he
is we'll show you some video on that but
here he is this was very clever by
Hannity uh he asked Newsom what Newsome
thinks of Biden and then actually showed
him some video of Biden before do some
got to respond it was quite beautiful
take a look
now my question is a serious one right
okay is Joe Biden up to the job of being
president and as a little reminder take
a look at your president in the monitor
met with the who those guys that fly
over shortly you heard of him
and the cheer from which year for Muslim
athletes like Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar and then you got Joe Biden
is having a hard time standing up take a
look at that one standing up take a look
at that one
I want you to tell me that you think he
is cognitively strong enough to lead
this country against China Russia Iran
North Korea and a new axis of Evil and
that he's the guy he cannot articulate
the economy the way you just did yeah
but I don't think he's capable I know
he's capable I see results I've seen a
master class of results the last few
years Master Class results now first up
you really need to understand Gavin
Newsom is in all of this only for
himself you get some public servants
some politicians who get out there and
really try to help the people Gavin
Newsom has well he's now worth probably
about 20 million dollars we've talked
about his Winery his relationship with
Nancy Pelosi he was the former mayor of
San Francisco absolutely destroyed San
Francisco has destroyed California about
a million and a half people have fled
California under his Reign but he
watches that video
now he became very rich throughout all
of that right so that's one thing so he
did it for himself it's all working for
him much like he kept his Winery open
during covid while he closed other
wineries that were bordering it uh and
how he also took lobbyists from
pharmaceutical companies out to dinner
at French Laundry up in Napa Sonoma area
which is one of the most expensive
exclusive restaurants in the United
States at the height of kovid no masks
indoors etc etc but Gavin Newsom it's
interesting what he's doing there he's
defending Biden but you know and
everyone knows Gavin Newsom is prepping
to take over for Biden they know that
right now we have a year and a half till
the general election Biden is breaking
down we all know it cognitively we can
see it physically with the Falls I mean
that fall last week where we showed you
the video and we threw back to it after
we showed it to you originally because
he could not get up actually he had to
have people lift him up after that the
guy is what 81 years old right is he 81
80 81 at this point yeah he's 81 years
old
he's struggling to speak he gets
confused you can see that stiffness
thing with his body these are all
symptoms of cognitive issues I am not
making fun of the elderly or people with
any cognitive issues or anything else
but it does not mean that they should be
leading the United States now Gavin
Newsom knows all that so you might go
well wait a minute why didn't he just
throw him under the bus because if he
throws him under the bus you might get a
little entropy behind it and then they
start figuring out a way to weasel Gavin
in but he is a he is a smooth political
operative if nothing else besides being
a lizard person and so what he's doing
there is he's backing Biden all the way
knowing that they will get rid of Biden
at some point here is my bold prediction
mark this down clip it copy it send it
to your grandma if Ron DeSantis is the
nominee it will be Gavin Newsom against
him there is no chance in High Health
that they will let it be Joe Biden
however if it's Donald Trump I think
that they will figure out a way to put
Biden back up there meaning like
optically you got this mind muddled for
cool but Trump is still old it'll remind
us of this old thing we'll all just do
the the repeat again right like we'll
just oh we've seen this show let's just
do it again the contrast however between
a young and sharp DeSantis versus a
really muddled Biden
I think would be a real problem but
Gavin Newsom is really slick so he knows
he doesn't have to do the Dirty Work he
can pretend to back him and be a good
Democrat and everything else while he's
stabbing him from the side let's not
forget remember a couple months back
when Biden was on an international trip
and Gavin Newsom just happened to show
up to the White House for meetings with
Kamala and some other people like
they're they're showing you their cards
if you get it guys anyway the uh the
interview continued and Hannity did a
nice job because Hannity brought up the
fact that San Francisco which is where
Gavin Newsom was the mayor and when he
took over as mayor it's about 20 years
ago now it was a flourishing absolutely
beautiful city that many people really
thought was the future of America
because it's where Tech was and people
felt oh the location and the weather and
everything else and the and the house
prices were going up and there was this
incredible renewal there and obviously
that's in stark contrast to the way it
is now uh
how did he asked him about that Whole
Foods did shut down one business but
there was a bad location to begin with
they're opening a new one we have two
point systems out here recently with
their team and I said don't go to the
wharf certain parts are bad and we own
that I just put the National Guard and
the CHP down there certain parts are bad
I'm telling you guys and you've seen the
videos every part of San Francisco is an
absolute nightmare crack pipes fentanyl
addicts everywhere stores closed
everywhere it smells like piss there are
literally people who look dead on the
streets are we going to show that video
right now we'll throw that video right
now you remember this one I just want to
show it to you again this is I I took
this video this is when I walked out of
Twitter so I'm upstairs you know this is
a month and a half ago or whatever it
was two months ago with the richest man
in the world look at this these are all
drug addicts this is a massive drug Den
I think this is Market Street which is
one of the biggest streets there and
then what you must understand also is
all the businesses around that are
closed the uh the Opera House the San
Francisco house it's about I don't know
an eighth of a mile away two blocks away
completely empty and desolate so he is
the guy that did that he has exported it
to Cali uh and mostly what he does these
days is lie about uh Ron DeSantis and
freedom loving Americans and America as
a whole we'll get to that on the other
side let me talk to you about Birch gold
real quick you guys know Congress once
again allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar as our national debt continues to
Skyrocket how are you protecting your
savings times like this are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold and you can do that
with the help of Birch gold and here's
the easy way to do it virtual to help
you convert an existing Ira or 401K into
an IRA in Gold you don't need to pay a
penny out of pocket as bricks Brazil
Russia India China and South Africa band
together against the dollar more and
more central banks are diversifying you
know what they're buying yeah gold
follow their lead visit birchgold.com
Dave for your free info kit on gold
there's no obligation just information
with an A plus better uh rating with the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers Birch gold can help
protect your savings too visit
birchgold.com
do it take action today uh all right
let's continue with Ron DeSantis because
you got to understand again as he has
destroyed San Francisco and destroyed
California this guy should be shamed
right everywhere he goes he should be
embarrassed but you know he has a
well-fitting suit I'll give him that
he's got his slick hair he looks like
American Psycho like he gets out there
and does what it is that he wants to do
or portrays himself however it is that
he wants to portray himself but mostly
what he's doing his usefulness for the
administration right now and I'm telling
you the Democrats they are just so
corrupt you just have to imagine they
have cut some sort of Deals they know
something's wrong with Biden they know
Biden's obviously on medication that is
some kind of Scandal by the way if the
most important man of the world is
having serious cognitive problems and
that's been diagnosed with somebody and
we just know it's true right you just
know I don't think I have to I don't
have the document in front of me that
says it but like if you use your brain
for a half a second something that Joe
Biden is struggling with you know it's
true
that means there's a conspiracy involved
because the wife Dr Jill Biden she knows
it maybe the chief of staff knows it
maybe Korean jump here there are people
hiding what the truth is and I for one
think that if the guy who has his finger
on the button to start World War III
which he's trying to lead us into with
Ukraine anyway uh if he has been
mentally compromised which by the way
when you have dementia Alzheimer's some
of these things it disregulates your
emotional Behavior you get angrier like
you're you're you have a penchency for
odd behavior Etc et cetera this could be
seriously dangerous
anyway Gavin Newsom is playing good guy
while they figure out that situation
it's fairly obvious and it's clear also
that they have tasked him with going
after the number one threat and who is
that number one threat yeah it's Florida
man himself Ron DeSantis we showed you
this clip a day or two ago but I think
it's worth repeating to just see the
dishonest attacks coming out of Cali
towards free Florida
these flights of Asylum Seekers that are
being brought to Sacramento there have
been two of them now they've been
described as state-sanctioned kidnapping
by the Attorney General of of this state
of California you tweeted directly at
the governor of Florida Ron DeSantis I
want to get this right you called him a
small pathetic man and asked quote
kidnapping charges is that is that what
you believe happened Governor the
Florida kidnapped migrants and brought
them to California I think I've been
generous small and pathetic
uh very generous he's just weakness
masquerading his strength
yeah he's flailing
desperate
he's so weak masquerading as strength
he's so flailing that this place is
wreaking expanding like you wouldn't
believe everybody keeps want to come
here keeps wanting to come here keeps
moving here keeps buying houses here
keeps bringing businesses here keeps
enjoying our beautiful weather and our
low taxes and our uh you know we don't
get fire raining from the sky which is
what they get in California because this
idiot doesn't know anything about fire
management either in far as management
and all that stuff but this is what he
does okay you guys get it so now let's
continue because then he was as we just
showed you he was on Hannity last night
and again he went after to say just
doing the job of the Biden
Administration
we're told they had jobs they told they
were going to get certain court dates
changed they were dropped off they
knocked on the door and they left and
there was not coordinated I mean what
kind of Faith tradition there was a
video of the people getting on the
because they were all lied to and told
and they were being taken care of
everything's going to be great I would
be proud and happy then then because by
the way because they landed in your
Sanctuary State you're going to take
care of them they should be happy look
we'll we'll deal with the car come on
this is California I know it's called
okay
on this way the fourth largest economy
in the world we can handle of course you
have this okay I'm a border state Rhonda
Santos is not I know he's desperate to
get into the ACT no because a lot of
people Donald Trump is going to clean
the Joe Biden DeSantis belly flop do you
you will clean his clock I don't have a
crystal attention and he set this up
months ago by doing an RFP I have the
contractor okay my question he tried to
hire saying he was going to send people
to California this is a stunt it's
embarrassing it's not pathetic
I think he did the right thing his
States
well Joe Biden just wanted to help
people will you apply the same standard
to Joe Biden he's flying all these
illegal immigrants coordinating them
coordinating excuse me I'm engaged
directly with the administration at 3 30
in the morning in Westchester
coordinating not LaGuardia not Kennedy
Westchester you know why because they're
sneaking them in when States aren't
looking and county is perfect but
they're coordinating there's a different
Spirit there's a different level of
Engagement it's different in daylight
and darkness it's not perfect there's
some humility in this oh isn't Joe Biden
dumping people in Florida all these
other states isn't dumb people anywhere
what's the difference between whatever
Joe is doing pre-test what does Santa's
manipulation hey Sean Hannity I'm going
to shoot you a text after the show today
you did a bang up great job there you
did not let him get away with any of
this BS you see what he says there at
the end you know every now and again
when they accidentally tell you what
they really think there's a different
spirit so when Joe Biden when they let
illegals into Texas and they Rampage
through El Paso and some of these border
towns and we see that they're taking
over the airports and crime goes up and
they bring drugs and they're raping
women and doing all of those things but
nobody cares about it it doesn't get on
the mainstream media except Fox uh
although if you send a few of them up to
Martha's Vineyard then all hell breaks
lose right but the spirit it's a little
different of spirit when they send them
from El Paso and some of those border
towns and they send them to the
Westchester airport in the middle of the
night at 3 30 a.m which is an absolute
fact we covered that a couple months ago
it's a different Spirit when Joe Biden
does it but when Ron DeSantis Rhonda
Santos who by the way has made no bones
about it we are not going to allow this
crap here so he's right Gavin's right
yeah Rhonda said to sign this months ago
saying if you try to dump these people
in Florida congratulations you are a
sanctuary State and by the way Ben Gavin
it's such fake outrage because then he's
like he's so evil but you know what
California can take care of him so then
go for it dude they're all yours enjoy
them bring them in you have a ton of
empty buildings in San Francisco it is
it is a ghost town bring in hundreds of
thousands of illegals let them with
whatever their cultural identity and
everything else and no future for jobs
in that of the city he let them
hang out with all the fentanyl addicts
and go to it again you've also got your
can we find out how many acres is plump
Jack Winery I want to find out how many
acres it's plump Jack Winery that is
what Gavin Newsom owns it's got to be 50
I don't know 100 acres maybe more like
give them some of that acreage man and
give them a little Pinot Noir there is
nothing that an illegal immigrant likes
more then you know what I mean you get
across the border you swam through the
thing the whole situation you get there
wouldn't you like a Pinot Noir I'm
talking not not a cab you know what I
mean you don't want a heavy red at that
point but you want something that's
light and refreshing up you know maybe
even a white wine a white wine spritzer
would be lovely you could do that Gavin
and it would show us what a good man you
are you have 42 Acres that's a lot of
acreage up there at plump Jack Winery so
get to it
anywho people so you see how far the
machine will go after to defend their
own right they will endlessly defend
people like Gavin Newsom and people like
Joe Biden who are destroying the border
and creating Sanctuary cities so it's
all their problems and then they go
after the people who are doing something
all Ron DeSantis is doing is saying hey
this is what I'm going to do and then he
goes ahead and does it and by the way it
has a lot more to do with what the law
of the land is we are a country and if
you come here illegally you are breaking
the law
so what else is a part of the machine
have you heard of this place it's in
Gavin Newsom State it's called Hollywood
California I used to live I lived in Los
Angeles Hollywood's a specific part of
Los Angeles and uh while I always call
Gavin Newsom a lizard person most of the
people who live in Hollywood are devil
worshipers now this is a slight jump
because two nights ago was the Tony
Awards now Tony Awards of course are the
awards for Broadway which are in New
York City but I think you can see the
connection between Hollywood and
Broadway well they gave out the Tony
Awards the other night and an actress
I've never I don't know this woman do we
know anything that This Woman's ever
been in she was in Hamilton I'm being
told her name is Danae Benton here she
is with a rather
brilliant political statement as she
gives her speech
[Music]
hi hi
I'm Danae Benton actor thank you and
proud CMU alum
[Applause]
or it's presented the 2023 excellence in
theater education award and while I am
certain that the current Grand wizard
I'm sorry excuse me governor of my home
state of Florida
energy
please please
pathetic
sell out elitist seal clapping
NPC nothings that's what these people
are there is not an original thought in
there her home state of Florida
or it was so racist her home state of
Florida that she became a massive
Broadway star in basically the number
one show on Broadway in the last five
years Hamilton that's how racist Florida
is Florida which has the number one
amount of small businesses owned by
black people Florida which has Law and
Order unlike Chicago so black people get
shot less much like white people get
shot less here in Florida but he's the
grand wizard of the KKK it is so
unbelievable and haven't we been through
this script before guys it's a script
this is what they did to Trump now they
know DeSantis is the threat and the same
people will do the same thing all over
again and I think we have to call him
out in double time see but speaking of
the same people doing the same thing can
we put up the warning we have to show
you it's a short clip from The View it's
just a short one today
it's Anna Navarro she doesn't like the
santis either and uh take a look
I just gotta respond to Ron DeSantis who
said what's really bad is one faction
weaponizing government against a faction
it doesn't like Ronnie you mean like
you're doing to Disney Mickey Mouse and
drag queens
look in the mirror you hypocrite
oh and uh you are a hypocrite you used
to be a roughly sane conservative you
worked or Marco Rubio you were either
his campaign manager or PR person or
whatever it was you live in Florida you
live in Florida as I keep noting she
lives somewhere near me okay like I'm
going to see her at a restaurant it's
gonna be nasty when when it happens
um yes okay we don't have to go into the
Disney thing you get why DeSantis did
the Disney thing and he took away
special rights and all that so that's
Disney and Mickey Mouse they're just
absolute Liars by the way Brock just
brought up a great point where we were
showing you the clip last week we were
showing you videos about how mainstream
media was going after Ron DeSantis
because he's friends with Clarence
Thomas so on one hand he's friends with
a guy who happens to be black who's a
brilliant legal mind that's a problem
then on the other hand he's also grand
wizard of the KKK every direction that
they can spin you and they will spin you
and that's also why lefties and these
NPC these non-playable character people
it's why they're so angry all the time
it's why they're not funny it's why they
never smile it's why they're miserable
it's why they want to CHOP Children's
genitals off because they don't believe
in anything other than what the system
pukes out at them and every single day
and they wake up with puke all over them
and then they're angry because if
someone barfed on you in the morning you
would not be happy but they are the barf
receptacle of the machine
but there is a reason why I say that
they are ideological opponents as
opposed to Simply a political opponent
right a political opponent would be
different than purely ideologically
different why why do I say that because
if you are not fully in line with the
Democrat dogma of the day again whatever
happens on any given day even if you are
a Democrat they will try to destroy you
so who might I be talking about who is a
ballpark sane Democrat at the moment
well it's a pretty freaking short list
but there is this guy RFK Jr right and
RFK Jr Robert F Kennedy Jr
he has been talking about closing the
Border because we have an immigration
problem he actually went to the Border
last week we showed you the video 2 A.M
hundreds of people walking by from all
sorts of different countries right
behind him uh he's talking about our
pharmaceutical problem and how it's
connected to our government and how they
abused us and they're keeping everybody
sick he's talking about the serious
stuff so what happens if you are a
Democrat and you don't tow the Democrat
line then they get the operatives out
there right they get the MSNBC hacks to
get out there and destroy you because
you as a Democrat are not good enough
for them here is msnbc's mehdi Hassan
going after RFK Jr and just listen to
the way he talks about this guy
forgive me but abandoned-backed Tucker
platformed anti-vaxxer conspiracy
theorist who's running on his Kennedy
name but can't count on the support of
the actual Kennedys is perhaps not the
progressive or principled or
anti-establishment or liberal Democratic
party Champion that he might want you to
think he is there's just so much dribble
there and liberal by the way Maddie has
nothing to do with Progressive it's the
most illiberal ideology there but just
listen to the way to Bannon backed so
the implication is he's Steve band and
back I'm pretty sure Steve Bannon is
still backing Donald Trump uh but Steve
Bannon might like hearing some of the
things that RFK has said about vaccines
the other one was Tucker platform well
yes it's true Tucker Carlson did let RFK
Jr on the show to talk I know that's
very scary for Democrats because the
scariest thing is that for the average
Progressive might be that a more
moderate Democrat might talk to a
moderate Republican or conservative
whatever you want to call Tucker and
then they they realize oh my God we
actually have more in common and it's
the hysterics that we're trying to get
rid of and then of course he calls him
an anti-vaxxer which the phrase
anti-vaxxer seven years ago had a
certain meaning now pretty much
everyone's saying is an anti-vaxxer the
covid vaccines did not work uh the
coveted vaccines caused all sorts of
vaccine injuries thank God I did not get
vaccinated none of my guys got
vaccinated in here how's everyone
feeling today by the way foreign
at once gave me a thumbs up everyone's
feeling good here but it is not just the
clown show at the televised mental
institution of MSNBC that is now lying
and trying to scare people from RFK by
the way RFK and again we're going to get
them on the show I have some differences
of opinion with him we'll get into them
it Big Damn whoop Big Damn whoop but you
see they want they want to Sully his
name destroy his reputation but not just
that you know what they really want to
do to get him and this is what they do
an awful lot of people they want to turn
everyone against you including sometimes
even your family and your spouse check
out this headline from The New York
Times two days ago Cheryl Hines the Curb
Your Enthusiasm actress is beloved in
Hollywood now she's supporting the
presidential campaign of her husband
Robert F Kennedy Jr is she normalizing
his office Dame his often dangerous
ideas and the quote is before this
really my world was just about comedy so
I could make light of things but now I
understand people are listening in a
different way and I know that it's
really important to them now first off
it's I mean it's kind of interesting I
happen to know you may not have known
that Cheryl Hines you know who plays
Larry's wife or Larry David's ex-wife in
Curb Your Enthusiasm is married to RFK
Jr that's just kind of interesting but
do you see can you put it up again one
more time Connor because it's the last
line there it's the last line is she
normalizing his often dangerous ideas do
you see how they are trying to scare the
hell out of their readers what are rfk's
dangerous ideas that he wants to close
the border so he wants to be able to
defend America while we figure out what
our problems are he wants to question
the pharmaceutical industry is that
dangerous he's questioning what we're
doing in Ukraine is that dangerous but
they need everyone to be scared scared I
would say scared and or stupid if you
were a New York Times reader in 2023
there was only one thing they are trying
to do to you and it is make you scared
and or stupid well I guess that's two
things but we can combine them into
scare stupidly scared how about that
but you guys get it not only will the
machine try to slander you censor you
and cancel you they will try to
criminalize and shame you throughout the
process now you see where we might be
going with this have you heard of this
guy Donald Trump uh rather boisterous
hair orange fella uh here he is today in
Florida he is in Miami once again it is
at a federal courthouse it has nothing
to do with Florida they may have just
chosen Florida because it's close to him
so Miami is close to where he lives in
uh West Palm Beach where Mar-A-Lago is
um but uh let's just jump to how the
mainstream media we'll get into some of
the actual charges in just a moment but
first let's start with how ABC news's
George Stephanopoulos and let's not
forget George Stephanopoulos worked in
the Bill Clinton White House so do you
think he has a political ideology uh
here he is reporting uh that there's a
good chance that the future president
might be a criminal or something like
that I guess he has plutonium and a
DeLorean he knows the future and we're
gonna have to impeach a sitting
president blah blah blah blah take a
look
good morning and welcome to this week
one year from today there's a decent
chance that Donald Trump will be sitting
in a courtroom as a criminal defendant
there's a decent chance you'll be set to
accept the Republican nomination of
President of the United States
and there's a non-zero chance that he
could be both a criminal defendant and
the GOP nominee now none of this is
normal but that's the surreal world we
are living in today now that Trump is
the first former president to face
criminal charges from the federal
government his second criminal
indictment in the last three months
that's funny I do have to say that
nothing that George said there was a lie
all those things are possible it's
possible that a year from now uh Trump
will be in court it's possible that he
will be the nominee at this this point
you can Flash Forward two years from now
he could I suppose be like being told he
has to report to jail while also being
told that he's supposed to be walking
into the White House any of these things
are possible that doesn't mean that any
of them are legit that is the issue so
just to be clear let's get you a little
info on what's going on from the daily
wire related to Trump former president
Donald Trump said Thursday evening that
he has been indicted in the federal
criminal investigation into his handling
of classified material the former
president added that he has been
summoned to appear at the federal
courthouse in Miami on Tuesday at 3 P.M
okay so that is later today now I want
to be very very very very very very very
very very very very very clear about one
thing here their without question is
selective prosecution here if we are
going to talk about who screwed up with
classified documents then we got to look
at Mike Pence who has subsequently
admitted it as vice president and as
vice president you don't get to
declassify documents Joe Biden who did
it as vice president where you don't get
to declassify documents the president
does Joe Biden was the vice president at
the time we all know about the garage
with the Mustang and it was completely
unsecured and everything else so if you
want to go after Donald Trump who was
president doesn't mean he didn't make
any mistakes then you gotta have one set
of rules for everybody so I think the
thing that most people are outraged by
right now is the selective prosecution
of Donald Trump okay so that I want to
be just very clear about that put that
in a box a lock box and let's put that
over here all of that being said that
does not mean that Donald Trump did not
do some stupid and or illegal things I
want to read you one portion here from
uh the prosecution uh from the the
affidavit uh in August or September 2021
yeah at the Bedminster Club Trump showed
a representative of his political action
committee his Pac who did not possess a
security clearance a classified map
related to a military operation and told
the representative that he should not be
showing it to the representative and
that the representative should not get
too close so that is the charge that is
one of the charges there's many many
charges if that's true like if you have
classified docs with maps of things that
people aren't supposed to see you can't
show them to people from your political
action committee you can't show them to
anyone who doesn't have that clearance
right so I think two things can be true
here this is an absolute farce and if
they want to go for Trump they got to go
for everybody but we know they're not
going to do that the Democrats control
the machine and they're trying to take
out Trump
well actually I think the other part of
this is they're trying to take out Trump
or they just want to you know if it
wasn't for these prosecutions with Trump
I don't think Trump has a lot of
momentum right now I really just don't
think he does I think DeSantis does and
that's why he's attacking him all day
and in some ways I think you could argue
the system is propping up Trump because
it wants him to be the nominee because
they know that he won't be president
again but we don't have to do all that
right this moment the point is I think
two things are probably true here the
selectiveness of this that I think every
single one of you watching this agrees
on like if you're going to go after
Trump and make it pointed it's it's a
political move to go after him you have
to go after the other people but they
won't
and that does not exclude the fact that
Trump probably did a whole bunch of
sloppy things okay like those two things
can be true but the overriding point is
the machine is just going to keep coming
for whatever reason whether you think
it's to prop them up or to take him out
the machine is going to keep coming
after him here is former Attorney
General Eric Holder uh basically saying
yeah they'll figure out a way to impeach
him again if he gets in the white house
again and we can do another impeachment
and we can Replay that whole thing
because that was fun wasn't it
well the notion that you could have a
trial
um defendant be convicted somehow when
the election be sworn in as president or
whenever it happens
um that seems inconsistent with our our
notion of of fairness of of the rule of
law uh at that point I would hope that
an impeachment proceeding um might be
considered
um not only considered Broad and
ultimately he would be removed um from
Office oh
well okay then so yeah if he gets in and
if we can just figure out a way to make
a whole bunch of people think he did
something and sure ignore what everybody
else did and buy it and did and Pence
did and blah blah blah uh yeah we'll
we'll throw another impeachment at him
like do we want to go through this again
and will we let these people drag us to
hell that's what we got to decide but
what this is all boiling down to and
again why people are so angry whether
whether you like Trump or not whether
you think they are doing this to inflate
Trump or to destroy Trump the point is
it is becoming increasingly obvious that
the machine the corporate press the
political machine and everything else
works as a in In Cahoots with the New
York Times And The Washington Post and
all of our uh three letter agencies and
they work in cahoots with the Democrats
like clearly they want Democrats it
doesn't mean their Republicans are great
right
um what do I always say you don't have
to be Republican but you can't be a
Democrat it doesn't mean that the
Republicans are great but the point
point is they work because for whatever
reason the power structure likes
Democrats more maybe it's because it's
there for higher taxes they're generally
more for war now like identity politics
is an easy way to control people like
there's probably some version of all of
that that makes the full set of
ingredients on this thing
um but here is cringe Jean-Pierre our
black lesbian press secretary telling us
that no no people this has nothing to do
with politics the Department of Justice
going after Trump has nothing to do with
politics there's nothing to see here
don't look behind the curtain nothing to
see here
here given the severity of uh you know
the case that a former president was
charged and the sensitivity of the
documents
are you concerned that the intelligence
review has not been wrapped up yet I
mean shouldn't it be expedited and what
can you share with the American public
about you know whether National Security
was threatened or not so look I'm not
going to as you've heard uh from my
colleague moments ago I'm not going to
speak directly to the case what I can
say and also the Admiral spoke to you
know the the
um the National Security pieces of this
certainly not going to go beyond what he
stated here at the podium what I can say
and you've heard us say this over and
over again this is a president that
respects the rule of law this is the
president that wants to make sure and
has proven that to be in his actions to
make sure that the Department of Justice
is truly independent and uh you know and
he said that during the campaign he's
restoring certainly the Integrity of the
Department of Justice and that is
something that's important to this
President and I'm going to just leave it
there guys there's nothing to worry
about Biden's a good guy he wouldn't do
this he's restoring stuff he's not
corrupting anything he's just doing good
stuff and it happens to always work in
his favor and take out his opponents
there's nothing to see over here close
up shop go home
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay here
's Donald Trump yesterday in Georgia and
I think he simplified it quite well
Biden is trying to jail his leading
political opponent an opponent that's
beating him by a lot in the polls just
like they do in stalinist Russia or
communist China
eating him away in the polls again I
don't know are they propping Trump up
because they'll just take him out
because they know there's no new Trump
voters and and DeSantis is really much
scarier
or are they really so threatened by this
guy that they're going to try to jail
him all of the inconsistencies in the
prosecution and all of that but why does
the machine want to destroy Trump and
really destroy anyone that thinks
differently say you watching this or
someone like me it's because they view
independent thought as a threat right if
you don't just swallow the nonsense hole
you are a threat to them so who's
another threat to them and quite a big
threat actually uh former kickboxing
champ and and ridiculously influential
social media personality uh who has
become a sort of advocate for men like a
I don't want to quite compare him to
Jordan Peterson but like a sort of more
fightery version of Jordan Peterson I'm
talking of course about Andrew Tate who
describes himself as the world's most
canceled man he went on Patrick Bet
David's podcast this is from a day or
two ago talking about what the system
will do if you stand up against it he's
referring to himself he's clearly
referring to to Trump to an extent and I
think he's referring to you know the
broader all of us
I hammered the point home and I made it
very clear that they had the intention
of trying to put me in jail I said
there's three lives they try and cancel
you and slander you and destroy your
name they don't just want you to
disappear from the internet they want
you to disappear from the internet in a
cloud of Shame they have to shame you
which is why they chose the crimes they
did for me and it's why they usually
choose the crimes they choose because
it's heinous they want to shame you and
they want you to Disappear With Your
Head facing the ground and never pop up
again
obviously they attempted to cancel me I
became more famous than ever before I
even said to you on your podcast and I
said on another podcast I said I think
they made a mistake I think when you
have power and you overuse it you what
happens is a rebellion that's how a
revolution starts when you have power
you have to be very very careful with
how you use that power the second you
overuse it there's a revolution right
and we're in Romania so they know all
about that that's exactly what happens
and I I said at the time I think I was a
mistake I think they made a big mistake
canceling me the way they did
and then the second time the second life
which I described as they try and put
you in jail for no reason here we are in
the current scenario I knew it was going
to happen and the third one is they put
a bullet in your head so we're gonna
have to see
how the second life plays out and
yeah I mean when this is all over and I
win the court case I get the not guilty
I won't be smiling I'll be walking out
the courtroom with my head on a swivel
that's the kind of life I'm living now
I'm gonna be thinking oh okay so their
second attempt failed
like do I want to fly private anymore do
I want to go that place anymore you
start to think about these things like
do I want to do these things law of
billionaires dying in plane crashes is
strange so
it's scary regardless of how it plays
out and I guess you just have to go with
the punches and and see where it lands
and God has a plan for for me and for
all of us and we're just going to see
how it ends up okay so just to give you
a little context on that I don't want to
get into all of the charges related to
uh Andrew Tate but they shot that this
is two or three days ago that is in
Romania he was in jail in Romania on
charges that I think they never fully
released actually for six months in jail
now he's on house arrest in Romania so
Patrick Bet David flew to Romania for
this interview the point is that that
Andrew Tate who's fighting the system
telling people to believe in themselves
and not believe the nonsense and believe
in biological reality and everything
else he's showing you this is what they
will do to you I am now stuck in Romania
in house arrest and I will eventually
win the court case but what will they do
to me after and I think there's an
obvious parallel to some extent with
what's going on here with Donald Trump
so how do we fight this thing properly
well it's partly what I always say it's
like you gotta get a little skin in the
game and start really understanding
what's going on here knowing reality and
sort of ground up building a life that's
good for you and your family and your
communities and then eventually we can
maybe uh dissipate some of this nonsense
right the other thing is when good
politicians come and there are very few
that come by but when good ones who
really get it come by you got to offer
their support and obviously uh Ron
DeSantis to me is the guy that is doing
that the best uh here he is yesterday on
what they are doing to Trump right now
is there a different standard for a
Democrat Secretary of State versus a
former Republican president I think
there needs to be one standard of
Justice in this country let's enforce it
on everybody and make sure we all know
the rules you can't have one faction of
society weaponizing the power of the
State against factions that it doesn't
like and that's what we've seen and
here's the thing there is obviously very
high profile examples but there's
examples of ordinary people who may not
get the same headlines a pro-life
Advocate may have 20 FBI agents storming
their house at six o'clock in the
morning you may have parents going to a
school board meeting in Virginia that
are being surveilled by the FBI so the
weaponization of these agencies strikes
at the heart of what it means to have a
free society and it's not just affecting
people at the top it's affecting people
all throughout our country the reason I
love that clip is because what he's
saying is he's absolutely defending the
weaponization of government against
knowledge one but then he's also saying
it's coming after you and that's the
part that matters so when he talks about
you know the parents in Virginia who
were fighting for school choice and to
get the wokeness out the FBI was looking
into them the pro-life people that the
FBI started looking into like he's
starting to show people oh there's a
connection and we must fight this from
the three-letter agencies by the way
there was another politician about 40 50
years ago who used to talk about this
quite a bit uh yeah John F Kennedy the
uncle of RFK Jr I want to show you one
more video to close out the show today
uh this is DeSantis same speech talking
about some of the lessons that our
founding fathers knew why they knew them
and why they're applicable to everything
going on today in our fight for a
well-functioning republic
four or five years and not have an
appreciation for how fragile Freedom
really is each generation does have this
responsibility to cultivate it our
founding fathers understood this when
they went to Philadelphia in 1787 to
craft our constitution they came armed
with the knowledge of having studied
every Republic in the history of mankind
because they wanted to draw lessons from
those experiences that they could apply
here in America and what they figured
out was all those republics there was
really only one thing that they all had
in common and it was this
every one of them had failed and so they
understood it fell to the United States
of America to determine Can people
really govern themselves can you have a
society based on the idea that our
rights come from God not from the
government that we live under a rule of
law not a rule of individual men or was
mankind forever destined to live under
various forms of despotism and they
fully expected that this country would
be the ones that ultimately decided the
fate of freedom in the world and when
Benjamin Franklin walked out of that
convention he was asked Dr Franklin what
have you given us a republic or a
monarchy he said a republic if you can
keep it they understood you could have
the best Declaration of Independence in
the world you can have the best
constitution in the world these things
do not run on autopilot they require
citizens to be engaged and to fight for
the preservation of these freedoms
wouldn't it be freaking beautiful
if that guy ends up president of the
United States who has not only made it
very clear that he understands what the
issues are he understands what we are
fighting but he's been the chief
executive of a state that is flourishing
and then could export that blueprint
that he has used in Florida to the
federal government and start hacking
away at some of the agencies start
returning the power to the people
instead of the deep State and all of
those things I think he's the best
chance for that and I think if uh for
for many of my audience members who who
are still on the Trump train and maybe
Trump will end up being president and
Ron DeSantis will remain here in Florida
and it will be just fine with me
although I don't think that would be the
best outcome to actually turn all of
this around obviously
um
if you're a trump guy right now you know
everything that he said there was right
and that does not mean that you hate
Trump or anything else but maybe maybe a
younger guy with the track record and
the right team and all of the stuff is
the way to do this so we got something
to fight for Donald Trump has something
to fight for Andrew Tata saying to fight
for Ron DeSantis says something to fight
for we got some people we got to fight
against Gavin Newsom media Hassan the
rest of these clowns uh and we got a
republic
if we can keep it we shall see we've got
a post game show for you at
reubenreport.locals.com in about 37
seconds we leave you with a cold close
it's about what Joe Biden eats it's very
important that you know what he eats
because he has nothing to do with
partisan politics he's a good man
sniffing here occasionally and some
other stuff but mostly he likes
spaghetti that's the takeaway of the I
just blew it for you he likes spaghetti
we'll see you on the other side bye
breaking news about about the president
so his favorite ice cream
is graters readers how do you greeters
Raiders I don't eat ice cream don't
I know chocolate chip and he loves a
good pair of sunglasses he likes
spaghetti
which is
pretty cool I love spaghetti too like
spaghetti with red sauce and so that's
one of his favorite meals
[Music]
laughs